environnement sa maison qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu es tout pâle attend assieds
toi je préfère rester debout
[Musique]
alors avant de commencer j'ai une info
pour vous vous avez des hémorroïdes
non mais paniquez pas enlever votre
doigt je vais vous expliquer en fait des
hémorroïdes tout le monde en a parce que
c'est juste le nom des vaisseaux
sanguins qui irriguent l'anus et le
rectum
elles sont disposées par paquets à
l'extérieur au niveau de l'anus et aussi
à l'intérieur donc on parle
d'hémorroïdes internes et externes
oui alors je vous voir et canet non y'a
pas d'hémorroïdes demi pensionnaires les
hémorroïdes joue un rôle dans ce qu'on
appelle la continence fine la continence
film c'est comme la charcuterie fine
mais dans l'anus non c'est faux ça veut
juste dire que les hémorroïdes aide à
garder à l'intérieur laisse elle aussi
appelé kaka et les gaz quand il n'est
pas opportun de les laisser sortir donc
maintenant qu'on sait ce que c'est les
hémorroïdes si on parlait un peu de ce
qu'on devrait appeler la maladie
hémorroïdaire c'est une maladie qui
touche aussi bien les hommes que les
femmes et dont on se plaint généralement
entre 40 et 65 ans enfin jeudi où je
veux dire les gens et en prenant un défi
alors là ce qui se passe pendant la
défécation c'est à dire pendant que je
crottés vos vaisseaux se dilate cela
aussi mais là je parle de vos
d'hémorroïdes là où ça devient
problématique c'est quand elle reste
dilater en permanence ça fait un peu
comme des varices mais dans le
alors vous allez me dire au diable
l'avarice et je vais vous répondre dans
le milieu hospitalier
cette blague est interdite depuis 1987
voilà donc pour résumer les hémorroïdes
ce sont des vaisseaux normaux qui ne
pose des problèmes que quand il reste
gonflé en permanence faut pas les juger
moi j'aurais voulu être un vaisseau
noble genre une coronaire mais bon je
suis retrouvé au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
c'est un gonflé j'ai mal tourné bon
alors vous n'osez pas me poser la
question mais je sais ce que vous voulez
vraiment savoir à quoi ça ressemble les
hémorroïdes externe ça se présente
généralement sous la forme de petites
boules au niveau de l'anus
parfois c'est rouge parfois ça saigne
parfois ça ressemble juste un petit
bouton je vous mets pas les photos on
est d'accord les hémorroïdes interne par
définition elles sont à l'intérieur mais
elles peuvent pointer le bout de leur
nez à l'extérieur soit quand on pousse
soit de façon permanente selon stades de
la maladie
ok mais comment on attrape sa ba ça
s'attrape pas c'est pas une maladie
sexuellement transmissible et c'est pas
non plus une infection il ya eu peu
d'études très poussée mais ce serait
plutôt un problème circulatoire et il ya
des facteurs qui favorisent les
problèmes tout ce qui fait monter la
pression dans la zone par exemple comme
la constipation la grossesse l'obésité
ou le fait de porter des objets lourds
il ya aussi le manque d'exercice
physique ou la position assise prolongée
ou ce qui irrite la zone comme les
médicaments
les plats épicés ou l'alcool oui alors
un truc avec l'alcool
si vous ressentez des douleurs vérifier
comme pas forcément des hémorroïdes
tu sais ce qu'on a fait hier soir toit
en gnc gueule de bois
bon c'est par là que ça se passe une
crise d'hémorroïdes mon gars une fois
qu'elle est installée la maladie
hémorroïdaire selon les cas ça fait mal
ça gratte ça saigne et ça peut même
donner l'impression d'avoir envie de
déféquer parce qu'elles prennent de la
place et que votre corps crois que c'est
des matières fécales
donc il déclenche l'alerté est en alerte
n'a qu'à aller rkk alerte claque à la
plupart du temps les crises arrête
d'elle-même mais elles ont tendance à
récidiver
et puis surtout il peut y avoir des
complications comme une infection in
hémorragie une thrombose c'est à dire un
petit caillou ou
prolapsus hémorroïdaires c'est à dire le
fait que les hémorroïdes interne sorte
et restent à l'extérieur
heureusement ça soigne les traitements
peuvent être légers des médicaments un
peu moins confortable des injections
dans la zone des petits élastiques pour
ligaturer les hémorroïdes du laser du
froid et ça peut aller jusqu'à
l'opération plusieurs formes
intermédiaires mais la plus classique ça
consiste à retirer les hémorroïdes et je
veux faire peur à personne mais je veux
pas mentir non plus après l'opération
ça pique ce que les plaies restent
ouvertes etc la cicatrisation prend
quatre à six semaines
alors une plaie ouverte vous voyez le
genre une plaie ouverte dans l'anus vous
imaginez est une plaie ouverte dans
l'anus quand il faut aller crottés voilà
maintenant que vous savez ce que c'est
et comment ça soigne je suis à peu près
sûr que vous n'avez pas envie que ça
vous arrive
ou alors vous avez des trucs chelous moi
je juge pas donc avant de se quitter je
vais vous donner deux ou trois conseils
pour éviter de malmener vos hémorroïdes
et qu'elle se vende buvez de l'eau et
manger des fibres pour avoir des joli
petit caca juste vous comme il faut pour
pas agressés tous ceux qui quand vous
sentez que c'est le moment ne vous
retenez pas allé déposer vos copains à
la piscine dès que possible et une fois
sur place
ne traînez pas trop regarder et essai
sur votre iphone
un autre moment faites de l'exercice
physique régulièrement ne serait-ce que
marcher 15 20 minutes c'est bon pour le
coeur en plus et pour tout le reste
aussi
ne restez pas assis pendant des heures
sans bouger pensez à vous lever
régulièrement pour vous dégourdir les
jambes et
vous dégourdir voilà maintenant vous
savez quoi faire pour éviter de vous
retrouver avec on se retrouve bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de votre anus et de celui des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien l'annus des autres
[Applaudissements]